what you have to constantly be on guard
for is that you're doing something
external okay
um remember one you there's no
mind aspect to the
external so there's no spiritual
component to it um that people F in all
the
time right but they don't have
any meditative aspect to it in the sense
that the ego tripartite mind is being
deconstructed and they're bringing
agency to the godm experience that
happens all the time anybody who
takes the Alchemy and materializes it
like any modern wants to do so like
people want to talk about key
tissues you're doomed to no
spirituality okay and then there's no
point to this there really isn't any
point to
so um you have to be ever on guard when
you do things externally
because by default now you put a ceiling
on your any spiritual opportunity you
might have had so as you're doing this
part you get some
yield okay there is your
Center you feel me feeling it okay and
then what you're
doing is instead of a rebounding
energy is you're using a marriage with
gravity in your
footwork so you're here then drop the
marriage's grav do you see that so my
foot is going to yield and then as I
drop I push into that Center see that
and you don't want to you don't want to
do that okay so at your level I'd
rather that
you uh put the foot down and then
drive as opposed to boom boom you do
this all
day and all you're doing really is
increasing your external M you see okay
it's not the same
thing
slide your
foot slide your
foot or put it shift your weight okay
not not mering